>> THE HOLIDAYS ARE HERE.
SO HEAD TO MACY'S FOR UNBEATABLE
DEALS ON A WINTER WARDROBE FOR
THE WHOLE FAMILY.
MEN'S BLAZERS STARTING AT
$49.99.
KASHMIR TOPS FOR HER FROM
$79.99.
AND FOR YOUR LITTLE ONES, MACY'S
HAVE THE FESTIVE FASHION THAT'LL
HAVE THEM SAYING --
>> IT'S TOO HOT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT ITCHES!
[ CRYING ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> TIS THE SEASON FOR WRESTLING
YOUR WIGGLY LITTLE MONSTER INTO
THICK WINTER CLOTHES.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
SO ALL MONTH LONG, WE'RE TAKING
25% OFF BOYS MERINO WOOL
SWEATERS THAT WON'T FIT OVER HIS
HEAD.
>> IF YOU STOP SQUIRMING, IT
WOULD BE ON ALREADY.
>> AND 40% OFF COZY CORDUROYS
THAT'LL PINCH HIS LITTLE NUTS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> CAN'T HE JUST WEAR HIS JEANS?
>> YOU DON'T WEAR JEANS TO
CHURCH.
>> AND FOR YOUR LITTLE GIRL,
IT'S HALF OFF ALL HARD, SHINY
SHOES THAT HURT.
>> OH, THESE SHOES HURT.
>> WELCOME TO BEING A WOMAN,
KYLIE.
>> AND 30% OFF ALL HOLIDAY
ROMPERS SHE'LL NEVER GET OFF IN
TIME.
>> IT'S WET!
>> OKAY, YOU HAVE TO TELL MOMMY
WHEN YOU HAVE TO GO.
[ CRYING ]
>> THE WEATHER OUTSIDE MAY BE
FRIGHTFUL, BUT AT MACY'S, WE'VE
GOT KIDS JACKETS SO BIG AND
THICK, THEY WON'T FIT IN THEIR
CAR SEAT ANYMORE.
[ BLEEP ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU DIDN'T HEAR THAT, BUDDY.
>> AND SAVE AN EXTRA 10% ON SNOW
BOOTS THAT ARE SO HARD TO PUT
ON, IT'LL STRAIN YOUR MARRIAGE.
>> YOU NEED TO PUT YOUR FOOT IN
SIDEWAYS AND THEN TWIST IT.
>> WELL, IF YOU CAN DO IT, THEN
DO IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND DEALS SO HOT, EVEN
FROSTY --
>> YOU NEED TO LEARN, MASON.
>> DADDY'S A DUMB ASS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND DEALS SO HOT --
>> OKAY, WELL, IF THIS IS GONNA
BE YOUR ATTITUDE, MAYBE WE
SHOULD TELL MY MOM WE'RE NOT
COMING.
>> AND DEALS SO --
>> OH, NO, AND MISS YOUR BROTHER
GETTING DRUNK AND ASKING TO
BORROW MONEY?
WHATEVER WILL I DO?
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> AND FOR YOUR NEW ARRIVALS,
WE'VE GOT PRECIOUS WINTER
ONESIES WITH SO MANY TINY
BUTTONS AND SNAPS, YOU'LL LET
YOUR BABY SIT IN A LOADED DIAPER
FOR HOURS JUST TO AVOID PUTTING
IT BACK ON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
PLUS, EVERY DAY SAVINGS ON
MITTENS THEY'LL LOSE, SHIRTS
WITH THE WRONG "FROZEN"
PRINCESS, SWEATERS THAT MAKE
THEM HOT, FLANNEL THAT'S MAKE
THEM HOT, SCARVES THAT MAKE THEM
HOT --
>> GOOD!
WHERE'S MY KID?
MARCUS?
>> AND BUTTON DOWNS WITH SHARP,
SCRATCHY TAGS IN THE BACK
THAT'LL HAVE THEM BITCHING ALL
SEASON LONG.
>> IT ITCHES!
>> LOOK, WE KNOW IT'S AWFUL FOR
THEM AND FOR YOU.
BUT, ONE DAY THEY'LL BE TOO OLD
TO WEAR CUTE LITTLE CLOTHES LIKE
THIS AND YOU'LL MISS IT.
SO SUCK IT UP AND GET DOWN TO
MACY'S.
THE CLOTHES THEY'LL HATE,
CREATES THE MEMORIES YOU'LL
LOVE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪